Esta es la prisión le fortuó de Moscú la
fortaleza del siglo 19 famosa por su
papel en las purgas de stalin los
prisioneros están casi completamente
aislados su único contacto humano es con
un único compañero de celda Con quienes
lo interrogan
la gente ahí está aislada del mundo
exterior tanto como es posible las
personas acusadas de delitos
especialmente graves son recluidas ahí y
la instrucción de estos casos suele
durar mucho tiempo un año un año y medio
dos años
es aquí donde está detenido el
periodista del Wall Street journal
evanskovic acusado de espionaje el 29 de
marzo el estadounidense fue detenido en
la ciudad oriental de ekaterimburgo las
autoridades rusas le acusan de intentar
obtener información clasificada de
defensa para el gobierno de Estados
Unidos ahora se enfrenta a una posible
condena de 20 años de cárcel el journal
y las autoridades estadounidenses niegan
rotundamente esas acusaciones y sus
colegas le instan a mantener se fuerte
Durante este Calvario
en este momento es casi imposible hacer
periodismo justo y objetivo en Rusia sin
correr un enorme riesgo y creo que la
detención de Evan realmente demostró lo
increíblemente peligroso que es porque
Evan simplemente estaba haciendo su
trabajo recopilando material como
reportero
el lunes el embajador de Estados Unidos
en Rusia visitó a gerskovic por primera
vez desde su detención Washington lo ha
calificado de detenido injustamente Es
decir de preso político
Moscú ha planteado la posibilidad de un
intercambio de prisioneros pero no antes
de que concluya su juicio